FOR THE GOLDEN  EDMONTON TOMORR.
>> WE TAL WIN AT MRYAN -- KREID
ADAM FOX WILL DEFEND IT WELL FO.
PLAYED ALONG BY
STOPPAGE.
>> J.T.: THIS WAS THE BEST HAS.
THAT'S A FAST PLAYER, ONE OF THE
FASTES COME THE FOR YANNI
GOURDE.
LEFT OF UP.
KAKKO DENIED.
TROUBA GETS INBLAIS.
SAMMY BLAIS.
THEY CROSS GEEKIE.
RANGERS ARE OFFSIDE AS THEY
CROSS. OVER.
KREIDER, GOODROW.
THE KRAKEN TAKE A BREATH AND
>> J.T.: HE REALIZES HE DOESN'T
.
GOURDE.
HERE'S
ALWAYS.
GETS HELP FROM THE CORNER.
L KICK OFF WITH WAY.
GIORDANO.
SCHWARTZ.
ON.
8:58 LEFT.E, A BACKHANDER, HE
SCORES! RIGHT
UPSTAIRS.
HE WILL CIRCLE THEWARTZ HAS HAD
MULT
TOMORROW NIGHT.T BACK.
VINCE SHESTERKIN DOING
STICK.
TRANSITIONED OUT BY NATHAN OR N
SWWAY, AND YOU SEE
ADAMTY NET.AKE IT TO THE EBERLEP